oh okay God hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to five
nights at Freddy's virtual reality there
so we will update just in time for
Halloween the spookiest time of the year
which means that we get to go back into
the world of five Nancy friends in real
VR now the last time I did this was
actually in Austin when I was filming a
heist with markiplier which is coming
out in you haven't seen the trailer yet
you really should it's really good I'm
really happy with it okay let me see if
it remembers my save because they had to
reinstall this bad boy I had to restore
this bad boy so if this bad boy doesn't
need to be reinstalled I'm gonna be very
happy sorry about my squeaky floor
that's gonna be annoying ngratulations
it appears you have been granted access
to additional holiday content press the
special button in the candy pail to
enter the Halloween hub I'm sorry mind
that this DLC pack is nothing more than
a festive holiday themed add-on which
has absolutely no hidden intent or
purpose so have fun why can't I eat this
shouldn't I be able to should I be able
to eat this also is this not optimized
for the index the thing alright whatever
you say let's do this whatever this
horrible DLC is gonna be I'm ready curse
of dread whoa oh wow
hi oh you shakin you shake it as much as
me oh my god I wish I could point my
finger at you for some reason I cannot I
used to be able to do that maybe oh yeah
okay alright okay
hey bud go for it
you uh you stay up there and don't come
anywhere near me your touch is beyond
bad touch oh shoot okay
ah hey is that a chica Jack O'Lantern
Oh Jack and chica hey dumbass okay
afraid of the dark coming October 29th
29th
what about October 30th that's the real
date pretty fudge bar oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
teeth meets you oh my god oh my god oh
oh my god still bonanza what nothing
whole lot of nothing
what about it inside you a whole lot of
nothing that's no secret anywhere crap
right here alright let's do this are you
afraid of the dark
I mean the answer is yes absolutely I am
NOT got him I'm the best flush King
patch press an old trigger whoa whoa
whoa I don't like that yeah whatever
okay let's try this my plush kids are
you little you'll bastards
oh [ __ ]
oh I hate it oh no not you
what you oh I'm gonna die oh I'm gonna
die oh oh what oh oh god its grip
enabled oh it's it's valving that's grip
enabled okay that's fine
squeezing I just gotta squeeze it like
some tumor [ __ ] oh where are you wait
wait wait hi wait wait some kind of
horrible Blume boy I breathe oh hi oh my
oh hey buddy how you doing
Fred bear listen buddy uh what was your
name again out of the air oh no thank
you
oh okay that's a big Noah now and I'm
gonna you're a thumbnail material sure
as day but listen I don't want anything
to do with you because I hate you I just
want to be blunt about it on fire you
suck okay I'm gonna try that again
even though I'm not gonna be able to do
anything about it but I'm gonna try my
best because my best is all I've got
yeah take some of that oh you've got
masks
oh [ __ ] well I don't know where you are
okay let me just assume I'm gonna die
again but I'm gonna find where you are I
don't know where they are
well this is done forgivable Oh what was
it oh oh hey hey whoa whoa that was that
a bat was that a bat no no no okay got
one okay cool we're fine Jesus
I really gotta squeeze this thing are
you are you little
shoots don't do that to me
oh hi
okay that's not good okay I can see you
to each other so we are that's how
friends work okay look II stopped I
changed my inter ocular distance I'm an
adult okay all right hey how you doing
are you doing there
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no not like this
not like this not like this not like
this I don't know where you are I don't
know where anything is yet oh hi my god
no wonder I don't see you oh [ __ ]
well who's it wait oh I see you I saw
that what was that a flash this is very
difficult this is very very very
difficult this very difficult very
difficult ha suck suck it's a big stroke
party for out lets you suck you suck oh
[ __ ] hi hello oh hi
okay so far so foggy I'm holy [ __ ] oh my
god Oh God Oh what was that wait I just
saw something
hello hi
but okay what are you doing can I get
six a.m. please now would be a perfect
time to go to 6 a.m. I can't see a
goddamn thing
[Music]
[Laughter]
alright well I win I'm the best that
ever was and I'm great hey wow this is
awesome
witcher's oh great cake oh man wolf that
is less good but this big review [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh eaten cry blue sad Barry wants I
mean that all right thank you very
delicious you you preach on that I think
you alright a spooky mansion no
something tells me I'm not going like
that danger keep out all right let's try
spooky mansion whatever this is I'm sure
it's great
holy crawl patty no way cross way you
know I don't want to do this you want me
to cross a hall why okay
crawl all I gotta do is crawl okay to
the window hole through the wall all I
gotta do is crawl oh god what's that
what do i do how do what crawl I don't
remember
I don't remember oh god I don't remember
how to crawl what do I do to crawl oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh oh
well I don't know oh my god you're
joking me your joke you're joking me
right now you think I'm gonna do this oh
my god
oh my god what do i do what do i do i'm
gonna die oh my god oh my god oh my god
I I mean oh my god
to anyone I need to do okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay
what do i do what do i do what do i do
what do i do what exactly am I supposed
to do about that all right
you can't do this to me Oh
oh [ __ ] did you see okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay all right
well that was great all right hey buddy
okay let's try this again I don't want
to so the trick is
don't go when the lightning goes
otherwise he's gonna kill you dead
okay
okay okay there's there's a friendly
face that's a friendly face hey okay
here's why look it's all good it's all
good
all I gotta do oh hey all I gotta do is
wait for foxy to clear out and then move
oh hi
oh you don't clear out do you what Elsa
what is with you what's with you what do
you do how's anybody supposed to win
this
okay oh okay good good good good glad
yeah that's good that's good that's good
that's good
that would have been death okay I'm fine
I'm fine
apparently I don't know why I'm fine but
I'm fine for the time being
oh okay fine I'm fine
the necks fine everything's fine
everything's fine this is all good this
is good i'ma stop let's stop for a
second
everything's good
I'm not by who who okay I don't know
what my objective is I don't know at the
end of the hall is how I can't go
backwards this is the awful this is
built like the worst thing I've ever
done this is good oh this is so I hate
this so much I hate this so much
oh god I hate this Oh God okay if he's
gone okay I think I can get past this
little gap here so I can make it past
the gap
lightning lightning you didn't see
anything you didn't see anything oh okay
oh my good my okay whoa whoa why oh yeah
fine where what what what oh no no no oh
god wait what is that what is that all
about what is what is what is that all
about oh [ __ ] hi what is what is what is
that behind me all about oh oh oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god
look I get out I what I'm good
what oh god hello Jason whoa sweet
jiminy Christmas
oh my god what oh oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god
[Music]
okay I think I can beat that one
I think what it is is once foxy turns
into a plushie then I just gun it right
that's that's gotta be the deal you know
what I mean that's got to be the deal
because once that happens definitely all
right okay so it's not it's not no no no
no no no no why already wait what no
that behind me is not that's not fair
that how how are you already behind me
oh my god don't oh my god don't don't
what are you doing what are you doing
wow this is dancers and it's not it's
not fair
oh stop it what are you doing uh-huh
uh-huh hey what's up oh oh god oh god oh
god oh god help
you're right in front of me oh god okay
I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm going
I'm going I'm going away oh my god I'm
just gonna go for it I'm gonna count
that that's not gonna kill me oh it's
going for it here we go oh okay you know
um I realized something today I realized
something
I realized you know I don't need to do
that I don't need to do I hate that this
I hate this but in a good way let's just
say that I'm gonna come back to that
because be a coup ass
I don't wanna be a coup as I am NOT a
baby boy I care about my sanity and
that's what's important danger keep out
push buttons oh that's really just push
buttons is that all I really gotta do
okay
use light to scare animatronics Oh so
the shoe is on the other foot survive
until 6:00 okay
easy enough okay wide stance to avoid
the squeak oh [ __ ] okay push buttons hi
what wait what oh I hate you in the
world what in the world what is this
garbage what what did I just know oh
[ __ ] okay what did I just do oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh no no no no no okay so [ __ ] okay yes
so what up hello hello what I'm
gathering from this is that you're a son
of a [ __ ] what is this happen
okay alright where are they I don't know
I'm asking you would you know oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I saw that oh I saw that
oh wait I see you it's on wait I still
see you wait we're not okay
did that get you by oh that got you that
better gotten you that better did the
giving of you that better do the getting
you think okay alright we're fine
everything's good everything's what's
that what what is it what is that what
is that what is happening
oh oh oh hate this okay I hate this
oh [ __ ] I hate this oh my god
[Music]
what is that what is that what is that
oh my god oh my god oh my god okay just
gotta give it to the old brother anybody
there
you know okay I don't know if I'm
wasting power but oh god no bad timing
oh no oh no I get did I get you might
have gotten yeah okay okay all right so
far still okay shockingly somehow still
on the up and up up and up up and up up
and not just a man I'm not even paying
attention to that anymore okay so I
can't just waste my power willy-nilly oh
oh oh [ __ ]
come on oh god oh god you okay
we're fine I didn't mean to do that I
see you in there I saw you
Oh got you charge my power now cuz I
know that I'm safe
I know I'm safe safe is what I am okay
okay okay I shouldn't waste power like
that I should what i splashed you I
flashed you flashed you oh I see you
there you know not today maybe they only
go back a little bit to do that I think
they only go back just a little bit when
you do that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
fook are you there are you there I'm
wasting power like nobody's beeswax
I've never wasted this by the power of
my life Here I am the biggest waste
surface the point got you both oh [ __ ]
you're still there point got you both oh
[ __ ]
I swear I'm getting you if it seems like
I'm not getting you it's because you're
a liar and I'm the truth die
[Music]
alright that was easy
not a problem yeah I get it
you all suck I am the best
[Music]
Oh fasces flavor Burstyn delicious
delicious what am I gonna get something
other than candy or is it only candy cuz
it's Halloween okay good yeah this that
was so good
I am never doing you ever again I did it
I beat all them guys what the hell what
the hell I'm tall I'm I'm serving a buff
world I'm so tall whatever okay good
anything in the other world here if I
say anything in the other world
afraid of the dark spooky mansion oh are
you coming this way hi are you coming
this way
are you I guess I'll wait oh no one else
what else here seeing this see it this
nonsense here no one else no one else
taking a castable can endure what's
going on here no one else concerned
about the inevitable doom that's
approaching me from the horizon the doom
of the Moon the curse of dread bear its
dreaded red bears coming I should do
something about this I really should do
something to prevent my imminent demise
it is clearly marching towards me and
yet I do not I do nothing come here I'll
give you a big hug you've been Oh
reaching out for a big hug me ye o come
over here give me the Snuggie oh god
this is bad I mean you're way taller
than I thought y'all not know who's who
now oh yeah that's what I thought not so
not so bad now when I'm equal height to
you I mean you I die
uii all right okay are you not coming to
me what are you doing no one can hear me
the mic is over there you okay man you
you alright are you in the normal way
too and I just didn't notice you do I
needed you okay do I need to call
somebody you want a soda
see ya you going to bed or ass catch you
in the morning
I'll make breakfast eggs bacon Gouda
alright well that's that that was
confusing not exactly 100% sure what to
make that but okay okay um all right uh
so that that's gonna do it for this
episode of cursive Dredd bear two of the
three of those are perfectly playable
very really Hoover enough these candies
so that was curse of dread bear thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to see me try to accomplish the
hallway crawl the good luck I don't gave
to peer pressure so I don't care what
you say also the trailer for a heist
with markiplier is out right now if you
want to get a preview of what's to come
in exactly six days check that out
there's a lot of cool stuff there and
it's really a lot of fun you guys are
gonna love heist you guys are absolutely
gonna love heist and with your help we
can blow it up into something big so if
you haven't seen the trailer go see it
if you have seen it share with a friend
let them know what's going on because
it's about to go down thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see more five nights at Freddy's
stuff it's in the description or over
there and they suggested and I guess if
you want me to play the hallway crawl
again you can I can't promise I'll do it
but it's a thing that could happen so
[Laughter]
alright anyway thank you and as always
Oh
see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]